Salut, ici Guillaume Hachez. Vous écoutez Septante Minutes Avec.
Salut à tous, j'espère que vous allez bien. Un grand merci à toutes celles et tous ceux qui ont écouté l'épisode il y a deux semaines et qui sont revenus vers moi pour me dire que ça vous avait intéressé et captivé le temps de septante minutes.
Je pense que vous avez compris que je n'étais pas très sûr de moi en publiant cet épisode tout seul, parce que je n'avais pas d'invité dispo cette semaine-là.
Et voilà, vous avez été nombreux et nombreuses à m'expliquer que ça vous avait captivé, ça vous avait intéressé,
mes retours, mes expériences dans cette démarche journalistique qui est la mienne et où je racontais aussi un petit peu ma vie.
Cette semaine, je vous propose un épisode peut-être un petit peu différent de ce que j'ai l'habitude de faire.
J'aime bien en général inviter des intervenants plutôt autour de sujets politiques dont, voilà, qui peuvent générer une forme de débat
où je peux challenger un petit peu l'invité sur ses positions.
Ici, je dois reconnaître qu'on est un peu plus dans une situation où mon invité prend bien le temps d'étaler ses connaissances.
Et voilà, et c'est seulement dans un deuxième temps, vers la fin de l'épisode, que j'attaque avec des questions peut-être un petit peu plus politiques, un petit peu plus sociétales.
C'est normal aussi vu la nature du sujet et vu la nature de mon invité qui est Jacques Van Rillaer, professeur émérite à l'Université catholique de Louvain, et on discute ensemble de psychanalyse.
Alors là également, je dois un petit peu remettre les choses en contexte.
Vous savez que j'ai peut-être un rapport particulier avec les questions liées à la psychanalyse puisque celles et ceux qui écoutent le podcast depuis longtemps savent que je suis autiste et que la psychanalyse a, voilà,
a eu des discours absolument répugnants autour de l'autisme.
Et donc j'ai, voilà, je ne suis pas neutre du tout et c'est assumé. J'assume tout à fait le fait que, on en parlait avec Alice Coffin il y a quelques mois.
J'assume tout à fait une démarche qui se revendique non objective. C'est une question de point de vue. Et donc,
voilà, vous êtes sur le point d'écouter un entretien d'un peu plus d'une heure entre deux personnes qui n'ont pas beaucoup de respect, n'ont pas une grande considération pour la psychanalyse.
C'est assumé, c'est voulu comme ça.
Et voilà, vous allez avoir l'occasion d'apprendre un petit peu l'histoire de la psychanalyse au vingtième siècle et toute une série de choses qu'on peut leur reprocher, à ces psychanalystes.
Et voilà, j'espère que ça va vous intéresser. Encore une fois, s'il y a des personnes parmi vous qui consultent régulièrement un ou une psychanalyste et que ça vous fait du bien, mais tant mieux, vraiment.
Je suis absolument pas là pour vous dire ce qu'il faut penser. Je vous propose simplement, le temps d'un peu plus d'une heure, un point de vue qui, voilà, que—
voilà, il se trouve que je suis aligné sur cette opinion-là, mais c'est juste une proposition.
Aucune obligation d'adhérer à tout ce qui est dit. Et je vous propose d'ailleurs de lancer les festivités dès maintenant.
J'ai le plaisir d'être aujourd'hui en présence de Jacques Van Rillaer. Bonjour Jacques.
Oui, bonjour Guillaume.
Pour ceux et celles qui ne vous connaissent pas, vous êtes professeur émérite en psychologie à l'Université catholique de Louvain.
Vous avez publié au cours des dernières décennies de nombreux ouvrages, dont par exemple plusieurs livres au sujet de la psychanalyse dont nous allons parler aujourd'hui.
Et il y a eu, entre autres choses, au début des années nonante, Les illusions de la psychanalyse. Puis, vous avez participé à l'ouvrage Le livre noir de la psychanalyse en 2005 avec d'autres auteurs.
Et vous sortez ce mois-ci une réédition de ce premier ouvrage intitulé Les désillusions de la psychanalyse. Alors, nous allons approfondir ensemble toutes ces questions.
Première chose, pour ceux et celles qui ne sont pas forcément familiers avec votre histoire, pourquoi avoir choisi d'étudier la psychologie et la psychanalyse en particulier ?
Oui, c'est une longue histoire parce que ça me ramène évidemment en arrière. Septante-sept ans maintenant. Donc
oui, alors, bon écoutez, je peux confier qu'à la fin de mes études secondaires, je pensais entrer dans les ordres religieux et mes parents, étant un peu effrayés, m'ont demandé de réfléchir un an.
Et donc je trouvais que la psychologie était une bonne solution. J'ai un peu hésité entre la psycho, la philo, enfin bref.
Mais donc, une fois étudiant à Louvain, cette idée s'est tout doucement dissipée. Bon, je me suis retrouvé finalement en psychologie.
Et à l'époque, si on voulait aider des personnes en difficulté psychologique, c'était la psychothérapie, la psychologie clinique.
Et donc, la seule chose qu'on connaissait à l'époque, notamment à Louvain, c'était la psychanalyse. Donc tout naturellement, dès ma troisième année d'études, je me suis adressé à la Société belge de psychanalyse.
J'ai voulu commencer une formation en psychanalyse. Et donc, ouais, déjà,
donc en troisième année de psychologie, j'ai été admis, non pas à la Société belge de psychanalyse, mais à l'École belge de psychanalyse, qui, elle, était plutôt lacanienne.
Mh. Mh.
Donc, voilà, alors, j'ai fait ma thèse de doctorat sur la psychanalyse, qui m'a beaucoup emballé.
J'avais la chance de devenir l'assistant d'un professeur qui avait beaucoup de talent et qui était un peu la vedette de la psychologie clinique, Jacques Scott.
Donc j'ai été son premier assistant. J'ai fait ma thèse de doctorat alors que sur
Freud, la psychanalyse, que j'ai lu en entier Freud en allemand, donc j'avais eu quelques cours des rudiments d'allemand en humanités, mais donc j'ai bien étudié l'allemand pour pouvoir lire couramment,
Sigmund Freud dans le texte.
Et donc j'ai fait une thèse qui a été fort appréciée. Mon jury était composé de quatre psychanalystes et un psychologue qui n'était pas.
Et tout le monde a dit que c'était très bien et que donc j'avais l'étoffe d'un professeur. Et donc, deux ans après, j'ai été nommé chargé de cours à temps plein à Louvain.
J'ai été nommé aussi aux facultés Saint-Louis, donc à Bruxelles. Et donc je suis devenu professeur en 1980.
Donc là, à ce stade, vous êtes un grand amateur, vous adhérez complètement aux différents concepts proposés par la psychanalyse.
À quel moment est-ce que ça commence à coincer, pour ainsi dire ?
Alors, j'étais allé, entretemps quand même, en 1968, qui est une année assez extraordinaire, évidemment, pour les jeunes, pour les étudiants.
J'étais allé aux Pays-Bas. J'avais reçu une bourse du gouvernement hollandais. Et donc mon patron, Jacques Scott, avait dit : « Mais c'est bien d'aller voir un peu ce que font les Hollandais ».
Ce qu'il ignorait, c'est qu'il m'a envoyé dans une université, dans un département où la psychanalyse était tout à fait déjà en désuétude.
Il y avait plusieurs assistants qui étaient allés aux États-Unis, en Angleterre, qui étaient revenus avec d'autres idées, notamment la conception rogerienne, la conception comportementaliste.
Et donc, ça a été pour moi la source de beaucoup d'interrogations et finalement, dans les années qui ont suivi, beaucoup de dissonances cognitives.
Parce que, par exemple, j'avais pu assister à des thérapies de phobie qui marchaient très très bien, alors que les phobies traitées par la psychanalyse ne marchaient pas ou très difficilement.
Les gens qui sont agoraphobes restaient agoraphobes, les gens qui faisaient des attaques de panique continuaient à en avoir.
Et donc, je constatais à Nimègue que tout ça marchait bien. Donc l'idée était : voilà, la psychanalyse, ça ne marche pas pour tout.
Il y a quand même des indications pour d'autres thérapies, mais je suis resté dans le courant psychanalytique pendant toutes les années septante, malgré tout.
J'ai fait ma thèse sur le thème de l'agressivité chez Freud et tout de même, il y avait des choses qui m'avaient dérangé dans les œuvres de Freud.
C'était en particulier le concept de pulsion de mort. Parce que Freud explique par la pulsion de mort un peu tout et n'importe quoi : les répétitions compulsives, l'agressivité, le masochisme, le fait que les thérapies ne marchent pas, les guerres, etc.
Donc ça apparaissait aux yeux d'un psychologue comme une pseudo explication. Donc, on a une entité interne qu'on ne voit pas, la pulsion de mort, qui expliquerait toute une série de comportements.
Alors, je n'étais pas le premier à penser. Déjà, un des disciples de Freud, Wilhelm Reich, avait eu la même idée assez rapidement.
Il était d'orientation marxiste. Et ce Wilhelm Reich, qui a fini par avoir des idées assez loufoques, bon, à l'époque, avait des idées intéressantes quand il a critiqué Freud.
Freud avait été très mécontent, d'ailleurs, de sa critique de la pulsion de mort. Il avait dit dans certains textes : « Bah,
ma théorie des pulsions, c'est un peu de la mythologie », mais dans d'autres, il disait : « Voilà, ça me paraît quand même comme une réalité dont on ne peut absolument pas se passer ».
Voilà donc comment j'en suis venu à mettre en doute assez bien la psychanalyse. En fait, j'avais écrit un livre qui s'appelle L'agressivité humaine avec comme sous-titre Une étude freudienne, qui est un livre tout à fait freudien,
mis à part la critique de la pulsion de mort quand même.
Et l'éditeur à l'époque, qui s'appelait Charles Dessart, trouvait que ce livre était bien. À l'époque, on vendait beaucoup beaucoup moins de livres.
Donc, il m'a dit : « Bah, vous écrivez bien, pourquoi pas un autre ? » Et j'ai proposé Science et illusion en psychanalyse.
Donc, je me suis dit : je vais faire un bilan de la psychanalyse. Et—
Ce qui tient la route et ce qui ne tient plus la route, ouais.
Exactement.
Ce qu'on veut garder, ce qu'on veut mettre de côté.
Oui, selon la bonne formule de Popper. Hein, donc, quand on fait réellement de la science, il faut savoir qu'est-ce qu'on met à la poubelle, hein.
Ne pas tout garder, pas tout réinterpréter à tout prix. Et donc, je suis tombé alors, en voulant voir aussi ce qui avait été dit avant Freud, que je n'avais pas suffisamment étudié pour ma thèse.
Je suis tombé sur un livre tout à fait remarquable d'environ mille pages, donc, qui s'appelle,
À la découverte de l'inconscient d'Henry Ellenberger, un psychiatre qui a été formé à la psychanalyse par un disciple de Freud, Oscar Pfister, mais qui n'est pas devenu un dévot, hein.
C'est quelqu'un qui est resté très critique. Et il a eu l'occasion d'être invité aux États-Unis dans ce qui était à l'époque le plus grand hôpital psychiatrique pour devenir professeur d'histoire des thérapies psychodynamiques.
Et il a alors fait des découvertes étonnantes en lisant énormément.
Et il est retourné en Europe parce que, notamment, il voulait en savoir plus sur une des toutes premières patientes ou la patiente traitée par la psychanalyse, Anna O., dont Freud parle très régulièrement.
Et il a fait un travail de détective. Il a trouvé une photo. Au dos de cette photo, il y avait une adresse de photographe.
Et c'est comme ça qu'il a retrouvé l'institut psychiatrique près de ce photographe. Et il a alors demandé à voir les archives.
Il a retrouvé les archives concernant cette fameuse Anna O., hein, Bertha Pappenheim, de son vrai nom, et qui a été présentée toujours par Freud comme étant un cas qui avait été délivré de tous ses symptômes.
Il dit bien tous ses symptômes. Il présente la thérapie par la parole, par la psychanalyse, telle qu'on la pratique au début, comme un cas donc totalement réussi, alors qu'en réalité, Anna O.
allait de plus en plus mal au fur et à mesure de la thérapie et elle avait fini par être internée. Donc Breuer n'en pouvait plus.
La femme de Breuer était devenue très jalouse. Elle était de plus en plus envahissante. Il allait la voir au moins une fois par jour, en général même plusieurs fois par jour.
Elle était devenue morphinomane. Enfin bref, c'était une catastrophe totale. Donc, il l'a fait admettre dans un institut psychiatrique où elle est restée cinq ans, avec des sorties, sans doute, mais quand même, elle y est restée longtemps.
Et après, elle a assez bien évolué, mais on ne peut pas assurément attribuer cette bonne évolution après cinq ans d'institut psychiatrique au traitement de Breuer.
Donc c'était très déstabilisant pour moi de voir qu'au fond, Freud avait menti. Et de manière tout à fait consciente, hein, parce que, bon, alors cette Anna O.
était une amie de sa fiancée. Donc Freud savait parfaitement comment tout s'était passé.
Il y a eu mensonge et l'efficacité de la psychanalyse était dès le départ très très très fortement exagérée, notamment donc avec l'exemple que vous donniez de la patiente initiale Anna O.
Oui, donc la découverte du mensonge, qui maintenant est devenue célèbre, d'Anna O., ça, c'était quand j'ai lu le livre d'Ellenberger qui est apparu en français en 1975.
Mais à Nimègue en 1978, ce qui avait déjà fêlé, si vous voulez, mes convictions de jeune psychanalyste ou, 'fin, oui, de débutant psychanalyste, c'était les critiques que mes collègues faisaient gentiment.
Ils me taquinaient très volontiers. La relation était très bonne, mais ils taquinaient le seul, dans l'équipe, qui croyait encore à la psychanalyse.
Et donc ils disaient : « Mais tu sais, c'est une science bourgeoise. Bon, la psychanalyse explique tout par le complexe d'Œdipe, la fixation au stade anal.
Enfin bon, quand les ouvriers manifestent, c'est, voilà une révolte contre le père, c'est œdipien, etc.
» Alors, ils disaient voilà, c'est vraiment une idéologie, une idéologie bourgeoise. C'est une idée d'ailleurs bien développée déjà par une série d'auteurs à l'époque.
Et alors, une deuxième critique, c'était la critique scientifique. Donc je suis tombé dans un département où on était très soucieux de faire des questionnaires, de faire
aussi une thérapie qui commençait à être plus méthodique, avec des enregistrements pour voir qu'est-ce qui marche, etc.
Et donc, bon, j'ai alors eu des discussions sur la valeur scientifique de la psychanalyse, pardon, avec quand même cet argument massue qui a été bien développé déjà à partir de 1935 par Karl Popper,
c'est l'irréfutabilité de la psychanalyse.
Donc le psychanalyste a toujours le dernier mot. Il y a toujours moyen, grâce au concept d'inconscient, de montrer que vous avez tort, que voilà, que vous refoulez, etc.
Alors, il y avait un troisième argument, c'était l'efficacité. La psychanalyse, ça ne marchait pas pour tout, loin de là, et notamment pour les phobies, il y avait quelque chose qui marchait beaucoup plus.
Lorsqu'ils m'ont demandé aussi de faire un séminaire sur Lacan, hein, et que d'ailleurs mon patron Jacques Scott est venu aussi à Nimègue
parler de cela, ils ont eu sous les yeux de l'un ou l'autre texte de Lacan, notamment le texte sur le miroir et d'autres.
Et je me souviens que quand Scott est parti et qu'il avait essayé d'expliquer des choses difficiles à expliquer, ils ont dit : « Mais tu sais, c'est du charlatanisme », hein.
En néerlandais, kwakzalverij. Hein, c'est vraiment couper les cheveux en quatre. Et ces concepts, et alors on comprend pas, on peut comprendre autrement, etc.
Et donc ça a eu aussi quand même un effet sur ma déconversion.
Dans le livre, vous parlez aussi d'un passage de Lacan à l'ORTF.
Oui, c'est un petit incident qui a joué un rôle majeur dans, au moins, ma déconversion à l'égard du lacanisme. C'est d'apprendre par un de mes amis lacaniens.
On était à un souper entre psychanalystes et alors il me dit : « Ah tu sais, il y a un petit groupe qui a étudié les deux dernières phrases du texte de Lacan, qui s'appelle Télévision.
» Enfin, c'est la transcription
d'une interview qu'il a fait avec son gendre, Jacques-Alain Miller, et il termine en disant : « L'interprétation doit être preste pour satisfaire à l'entrepris, car ce qui perdure ne parie que du père au pire.
» Ils avaient passé deux soirées à essayer de comprendre, surtout la dernière phrase. Et l'un d'eux, qui avait la chance de faire ses contrôles à Paris chez Lacan, a demandé au maître : « Qu'est-ce que ça veut dire ?
» Et il, ça m'a porté que Lacan lui a répondu : « Oh, mais j'ai dit ça pour les assonances. » Donc en fait, Lacan n'avait même pas voulu dire quelque chose de sensé.
Il avait jonglé avec les mots et donc les disciples avaient cherché vainement pendant deux soirées une interprétation profonde.
Vainement. Enfin, ils avaient trouvé des interprétations, mais ils se demandaient si c'était la bonne.
Donc, j'ai alors bien compris qu'au fond, il y a une série de phrases qui sont vraiment du non-sens, qu'il ne faut pas chercher un sens à ça.
Et ça, évidemment, ça va tout à fait à l'encontre de l'éthique des chercheurs scientifiques, notamment de l'éthique que j'avais alors commencé à développer à partir de mon passage en Hollande.
Lorsqu'on fait de la science, de la recherche, etc., il faut être clair sur la méthode utilisée, les résultats. Il faut que le langage permette à des collègues de refaire les mêmes recherches, de faire des recherches réplicatives.
Or, avec Lacan, on interprétait et on ne savait jamais ce que le maître avait vraiment voulu dire. D'ailleurs, j'avais demandé à
mon patron Jacques Scott, donc, qui était lacanien, à l'une ou l'autre occasion, j'étais venu avec un texte en disant : « Mais écoutez, je ne comprends absolument pas.
» Et il m'avait répondu, avec un petit sourire en coin : « Il faut laisser circuler le signifiant. » J'avais trouvé que c'était un peu court.
En tout cas, ce n'était pas le genre de réponse que mes collègues de Nimègue appréciaient. Donc voilà, progressivement, d'abord Lacan, à mes yeux, est devenu, disons même un charlatan.
Hein. Alors il a peut-être dit des choses intéressantes, il a, par-ci par-là, de jolies formules, mais Lacan n'a rien apporté à la clinique.
Et par la suite, alors quand même, j'ai constaté, notamment en lisant le livre d'Ellenberger, qu'au fond, Freud lui-même, ce n'était pas tellement sérieux.
Je reviens sur ce que vous expliquiez, un certain charlatanisme. Vous évoquiez, voilà, des explications qui, finalement, n'avaient aucun sens, mais c'était juste pour l'assonance.
Oui.
Une démarche qui s'assume finalement comme étant non scientifique, hein, quand on va interroger des psys, des psychanalystes, même aujourd'hui, en France, et qu'on leur reproche ce manque d'approche scientifique,
leur réponse va être d'assumer parfaitement : « Ah, mais ce n'est pas de la science, ça, ça ne se veut pas être de la science ».
C'est assumé comme tel. Ma question, c'est
: à partir du moment où toutes ces choses-là sont assumées, comment est-ce que cela peut encore garder sa crédibilité aujourd'hui sur ce que j'appellerais un marché du soin de santé, la santé mentale ? On a
les psychiatres, des médecins qui ont étudié la neurologie. On a des psychologues, les TCC, hein,
thérapie cognitive et comportementale, qui ont fait leurs preuves, comme vous l'expliquiez, des gens qui arrivent à guérir des phobies, à soigner pour de vrai, alors que la psychanalyse
n'a jamais vraiment eu vocation à soigner, ou à guérir en tout cas.
Comment est-ce qu'une psychanalyse qui s'assume comme étant non scientifique peut encore subsister et trouver une clientèle de nos jours ?
Oui, il y a beaucoup de réponses qu'on peut donner. Pourquoi est-ce que les gens croient des choses qui peuvent apparaître absurdes ?
Bah, notez que c'était mon cas de croire des choses absurdes. Alors d'abord, il faut rappeler que nous croyons très facilement.
Nous sommes des êtres crédules, par constitution génétique, parce que si les enfants n'étaient pas facilement crédules, s'ils disaient : « Moi, je vais toujours faire mon expérience moi-même », bah peut-être que nous ne serions pas là.
Donc, croire les autorités, les parents, etc. est une condition de survie en quelque sorte. Et donc, la pensée rationnelle est une démarche relativement récente dans l'histoire de l'humanité
et actuellement encore, la réflexion très critique, rationnelle et qui exige des preuves aussi empiriques,
bah, c'est la démarche d'une minorité, hein.
Ça paraît un peu prétentieux de dire, puisque je me considère dans ce groupe, mais finalement, voyez le nombre de gens intelligents, même surdoués, qui croient, par exemple, toutes les religions.
Cicéron, les plus grands penseurs de l'Antiquité croyaient dans la religion romaine, hein. Et les grands penseurs aussi grecs croyaient dans la religion grecque.
Et donc, bon, beaucoup de gens croient la religion chrétienne. Et puis, il y a au moins un milliard aussi de personnes qui croient les histoires que l'on lit dans le Coran qui me paraissent complètement dingues.
Voilà, c'est un phénomène collectif aussi, hein. C'est dans la mesure où il y a des figures d'autorité, hein, les professeurs, des personnes qui sont
bien placées dans les masses médias et aussi, si vous voulez, les collègues,
c'est en fonction de ça qu'on croit.
Et d'ailleurs, si ma démarche critique s'est développée à partir de 1968, ce n'est pas parce que mon quotient intellectuel est meilleur que celui de mes collègues qui, eux, sont restés psychanalystes.
C'est parce que j'ai été aux Pays-Bas et que je suis tombé dans un groupe qui n'y croyait plus, qui disait : « Il y a autre chose et qui marche mieux et qui est plus scientifique, qui est plus sérieux, plus objectif ».
Donc, si j'étais allé à Paris,
je serais peut-être encore aujourd'hui psychanalyste, hein. Alors en France, évidemment, la psychanalyse a réussi, pour diverses raisons que je peux développer, si vous voulez,
a réussi à vraiment pénétrer dans toute la culture, le vocabulaire, mais aussi les idées, la philosophie, la thérapie, les institutions, etc. Et donc...
Et la culture étant finalement une forme de ciment qui nous lie collectivement ensemble. Et puisque la psychanalyse joue un rôle très important, particulièrement en France, particulièrement à Paris, ça, voilà, ça a ce rôle de,
presque inquestionnable.
Est-ce qu'on peut dire ça ? De dire : « Mais c'est l'évidence même », quoi.
Oui, oui. Oui, oui. Alors, il y a plusieurs facteurs qui expliquent ça, dont deux qui sont vraiment très importants.
D'abord, les Français au lycée ou dans le collège ont tous un cours de philosophie. Et quand vous regardez le programme du cours, il est bien indiqué qu'il faut parler de l'inconscient.
Et quand on parle de l'inconscient, on parle très facilement de Freud.
Donc beaucoup de ces professeurs de philosophie qui n'ont pas de formation scientifique, enfin, il y a des,
des philosophes, bien sûr, qui sont d'excellents épistémologues, je pourrais citer des noms, mais enfin, en général, donc dans ce cours de philosophie,
on fait plutôt l'apologie de Freud que sa critique, en tout cas autrefois, hein, et même encore maintenant, pour une large part.
Alors, il y a un autre phénomène qui est ce qu'on peut appeler l'effet Lacan. Et là, il faut faire un peu d'histoire, si vous permettez de développer pendant trois, quatre minutes.
Il faut savoir que Lacan a commencé dans les années 50, à faire surtout des didactiques, hein, c'est-à-dire des psychanalyses qui ne servaient plus du tout à guérir.
Il n'a plus pris des patients, mais essentiellement des personnes qu'il allait former à la psychanalyse. C'est ce que Freud a fait aussi.
À partir des années 10, il ne prend pratiquement plus aucun patient en thérapie. Il fait de la formation, donc il fait des psychanalyses didactiques et il fait des disciples.
Alors c'est ce que fait Lacan, mais à la différence de Freud, qui consacrait à peu près cinquante minutes à chaque heure de consultation, Lacan va faire ça de plus en plus vite.
Et finalement, il ne prend plus que quelques minutes par séance, cinq minutes. Enfin, il fait une dizaine de séances par heure, hein.
Et l'association française, la Société française de psychanalyse, s'émeut de ce système de formation en, à la chaîne, en quelque sorte.
Aussi l'Association internationale. Une enquête est ouverte et pendant une dizaine d'années, la Société internationale va faire des reproches à Lacan.
Et finalement, en 1964, ses didactiques ne sont plus reconnues. À ce moment-là, il fait cinquante, soixante didactiques par jour, hein.
Donc il devient très riche aussi d'ailleurs, et il a de plus en plus de pouvoir puisqu'il a de plus en plus de disciples.
Et Lacan, alors, comme ses didactiques ne peuvent plus être reconnues par l'Association internationale, décide de fonder sa propre école, hein, l'École freudienne de Paris.
Et là, il fait ce qu'il veut, évidemment, pour les didactiques, mais il va en plus ouvrir très largement la psychanalyse à toute personne qui veut devenir psychanalyste pour autant qu'elle ait quand même un peu de formation.
Alors que de l'École de Freud, il fallait un diplôme-
Oui, alors dans l'École internationale, il faut avoir fait la médecine, la psychiatrie, la psychologie. Alors chez Lacan, non.
Donc moi, j'ai connu personnellement un artiste peintre qui s'appelait Munt, qui était peintre à Paris, qui a fait une analyse chez Lacan pour des raisons très personnelles, thérapeutiques.
Et puis il a cessé la peinture et il est passé, il a acheté un fauteuil, un divan, il était psychanalyste. Donc,
on a trouvé dans l'association freudienne des, ah bah, d'ailleurs, les grands noms de la psychanalyse actuelle, ceux qui sont dans les médias, les frères Miller, Foulcault-Dinesco.
Aucun de ceux-là n'a fait la psychologie ou la psychiatrie. Foulcault-Dinesco est historienne, les frères Miller sont des philosophes, etc.
Et donc, il y a eu de plus en plus de lacaniens. En France, il y a au moins cinq mille, six mille lacaniens, alors qu'il y a quelques centaines de psychanalystes de la Société internationale.
Et ces lacaniens, donc, sont souvent des lettrés, beaucoup de philosophes, des profs de lettres, enfin, etc.,
qui sont aussi entrés dans les médias, hein, ou--
Et donc, la psychanalyse ainsi s'est développée aussi à la faveur de Mai 68, puisque Lacan parlait de la libération du désir et donc apparaissait comme un grand contestataire, hein, de l'ordre établi.
Et la psychanalyse, qui avait été considérée jusque-là comme étant plutôt conservatrice, va être considérée par un certain nombre de personnes comme étant progressiste.
Et donc, il va y avoir une jointure avec, si vous voulez, aussi, des gens de gauche. Et le catholicisme aussi va accepter la psychanalyse alors qu'elle avait été réticente.
Pas mal d'anciens jésuites vont devenir psychanalystes, hein, comme par exemple François Foustan, Vasse, etc. Et donc tout ça fait que la France est devenue vraiment la nation freudienne.
Il y a d'ailleurs une sociologue du MIT qui est venue étudier le phénomène,
qui a écrit un livre qui s'appelle La France freudienne, où elle s'interroge sur les raisons pour lesquelles c'est en France que la psychanalyse se maintient le mieux et s'est développée comme nulle part ailleurs dans le monde occidental.
Alors, ça s'est fort développé aussi en Argentine, relativement au Brésil. Mais donc, c'est essentiellement la France qui est le pays de la psychanalyse.
Bien sûr. Et à quelle conclusion est-elle arrivée pour ses explications ?
Bah, elle parle beaucoup de la fascination pour ce langage ambigu, notamment de,
de Lacan, qui permettait à tout le monde de faire de l'interprétation avec quelques rudiments et des formules que l'on répète, de paraître profond et de faire partie aussi d'une élite intellectuelle.
Le charlatanisme, le-
Oui, oui, oui.
Les formules, le paraître très intelligent alors que finalement...
Elle dit aussi des choses un peu désagréables. Elle dit que les Français sont assez narcissiques et que donc la psychanalyse, c'est par excellence une démarche centrée sur soi où on peut parler à perte de vue.
Il suffit de payer l'analyste et vous pouvez, pendant des années, parler de vous-même. C'est ce qu'on voit, par exemple, avec Luchini, qui se vante toujours depuis quarante ans.
Et Carla Bruni aussi.
Oui, Carla Bruni aussi, qui dit : « Voilà, la psychanalyse, c'est ma vie ». Pourquoi est-ce que Luchini, depuis quarante ans, est en analyse et se vante bien sûr d'être en analyse.
Personne ne se vante d'être depuis quarante ans en psychiatrie.
Mais dire : « Voilà, bah je suis en psychanalyse », ça montre un certain standing,
ça montre que vous pouvez payer, évidemment, l'analyse et que vous vous connaissez d'une façon extrêmement profonde, beaucoup mieux que n'importe qui d'autre.
Et que vous n'êtes pas une personnalité simple. Vous-- Il y a une complexité dans votre fonctionnement, dans votre nature.
Voilà. Bon, est-ce que vous adhérez à cette analyse un brin méprisante du fait que les Français sont, par essence, plus narcissiques que les autres ?
Ah, vous savez, je constate que c'est un peuple très difficile à gérer, hein.
D'accord.
C'est la moindre des choses. Mais parler de narcissisme, bon, je pense que ça, c'est quand même... Bon, je ne-
C'est un petit peu-
Je vais pas souscrire à-
La psychologie de comptoir.
Oui, je vais pas souscrire à cette étiquette peu sympathique.
Il me semble aussi. La France, et je vais évidemment poser la question de notre petite Belgique francophone : quelle était la situation il y a trente ans dans les universités belges francophones ?
Est-ce que-- Ce qu'on m'a longtemps dit, et je,
j'ai, je détecte régulièrement un malaise au niveau de cette question, ce qu'on m'a longtemps dit, c'est que l'ULB, l'Université libre de Bruxelles, était un bastion de la psychanalyse pendant très longtemps et puis que ça a changé.
Est-ce que c'est juste ?
Alors, au départ, non. Il y a eu des grands noms de la psychologie, comme Ongedaan et d'autres-
Mmh.
Donc des psychologues qui ont vraiment été importants à leur époque et qui n'étaient pas du tout de ce courant.
Donc, je ne sais pas exactement quand la psychanalyse a vraiment fait son entrée à l'ULB, mais ce qui était le bastion de la psychanalyse en Belgique, pour toute la Belgique, c'était Louvain.
D'accord.
Vraiment.
Donc au contraire, là où vous étiez finalement.
Oui oui, avec Jacques Scott, avec Verghoote, avec de Waele, enfin, etc.
Et puis ça a changé ?
Et puis ça a changé. Alors Louvain a progressivement changé dans un autre sens. Donc la psychanalyse, maintenant,
n'est plus du tout dominante, alors que, en psychologie clinique, la psychanalyse est encore le modèle tout à fait privilégié,
à l'ULB,
mais ce n'est pas toute la psychologie.
Il y a d'ailleurs de remarquables psychologues cognitivistes qui font des recherches sur les processus mentaux, etc.
Donc ce n'est pas toute la psychologie de l'ULB, mais bien le département de psychologie clinique.
Clinique, oui, précisément. Quand j'avais interrogé le vice-doyen de la faculté de psychologie de l'ULB,
on m'avait expliqué qu'il restait peut-être un professeur sur l'ensemble de la faculté de psychologie qui était, voilà, un psychanalyste revendiqué.
Mais on m'avait expliqué que ça appartenait plutôt au passé.
Oui, je pense que c'était un peu ce qu'il souhaitait. Mais le professeur lacanien qui a été doyen longtemps a une forte influence.
Oui, maintenant, en psychologie clinique, il n'y a pas grand monde. Ce n'est pas un département fort développé, mais, bon, la plupart des étudiants étaient astreints à étudier des textes qu'ils ne comprenaient pas quoi.
Et donc, je pose cette question parce que moi-même, en fait, quand je remonte dans le temps,
je crois que c'était en 2009, quand j'étais en enseignement catholique en secondaire, ma prof de religion, très naturellement, de la même manière que vous expliquez que en France-
Oui.
Dans le contexte du cours de philosophie, il y avait, voilà, des notions freudiennes. Très naturellement, cette professeure de religion en troisième année de secondaire nous a expliqué le complexe d'Œdipe de manière très,
très décomplexée, très naturelle, comme si c'était l'évidence inquestionnable.
Voilà, elle nous expliquait que c'était comme ça pour tout le monde, que ça arrivait. Et on a eu une série de cours sur des questions de ce style.
Du coup, ça nous amène au fameux pilier. Il y en a certains qui sont plus importants que d'autres, mais commençons par celui qui est sans doute un des plus connus, le complexe d'Œdipe, justement.
Oui, oui.
Vous expliquez dans le livre que c'est en fait la situation de Freud lui-même-
Oui.
Qui l'a extrapolée et qui l'a généralisée à toute la population.
Oui, oui. Oui, alors, ce qu'on vous a peut-être raconté dans le cours de religion,
ce qui était d'ailleurs très fréquent, hein, c'est que donc les garçons ont une nette préférence pour leur mère et qu'ils ont de l'hostilité pour le père.
Ben, c'est pas du tout ça que Freud raconte. Freud dit très clairement : Ce que le garçon souhaite, c'est de tuer son père.
Au sens propre, oui.
Au sens fort.
Mmh.
Et ça, jusque dans son dernier livre, L'Abrégé de psychanalyse de 1939. Et il dit aussi que à l'égard de sa maman, hein, c'est pas simplement aimer la maman, c'est coucher avec elle, hein, avoir avec elle des relations sexuelles.
C'est ça le rêve du petit garçon, du petit Hans, par exemple, etc. Donc, il y a une version populaire que tout le monde accepte.
On dit : Ah, vous savez, mon petit garçon a dit qu'il voulait épouser sa maman. C'est le complexe d'Œdipe. Non, c'est pas du tout ça que Freud raconte, hein.
Si vous prenez l'ouvrage, hein... Or, si vous allez voir sur Internet des émissions, on vous raconte la version populaire.
Tout le monde adhère à ça, ça paraît normal. Mais Freud, jusque dans son dernier livre, dit : S'il y a bien une chose qui m'a valu des critiques acerbes, c'est ce que j'ai raconté sur le complexe d'Œdipe, c'est-à-dire la version hard, hein.
Oui. Et qui plus est, le mythe originel de l'Antiquité avait finalement plutôt un sens qui était de, voilà, la corruption du pouvoir, de-
Oui, oui.
L'Œdipe qui devient le roi. Qu'est-ce qui lui arrive mentalement ?
La folie du pouvoir.
Et aujourd'hui, quand on raconte ce mythe-là, on a tendance justement à le lire à travers le prisme freudien qui est-
Oui, oui.
Ah ben, en fait, c'est l'histoire d'un gars qui épouse sa mère et qui tue son père.
C'est ça le focus, alors que c'est plutôt le symptôme, voilà, d'autre chose dans le mythe originel.
Oui, oui. Dans le mythe, en fait, Œdipe tue un inconnu, hein. Il sait pas que c'est son père. Il le tue d'abord, hein, et ensuite, il épouse sa mère sans savoir que c'est sa mère, hein.
Mais dans le mythe tel que Freud l'a constitué, et qui n'est pas le mythe d'Œdipe classique, c'est parce qu'il y a d'abord l'amour de la mère, le désir de coucher avec elle, qu'on a envie de tuer le père.
Dans la pièce, c'est exactement l'inverse. En fait, cette histoire de complexe d'Œdipe tel que Freud l'a toujours formulée dès le début, c'est sa propre histoire.
Lui-même avoue dans une lettre à Fliess que sa libido s'est développée à l'égard de sa mère, hein. Et on voit aussi l'hostilité à l'égard de son père.
Ferenczi, qui était un de ses disciples préférés, disait : Freud détestait son père, il aurait voulu le tuer. Et donc, Freud écrit à Fliess, hein, en-
1897, après que Fliess lui dit : « Voilà, mon fils a vu sa mère nue et a eu une érection.
» Alors, Freud dit : « Mais c'est ce qui m'est arrivé moi aussi, j'ai éprouvé de la libido pour ma mère » et,
il écrit quelques jours après et c'est ça qui explique le succès universel de la pièce de Sophocle, hein.
Ce qui n'est quand même pas universel. Je me souviens avoir vu cette pièce quand j'avais 18, 19 ans. Ça ne m'avait pas emballé plus que ça de voir Œdipe qui se crevait les yeux.
Et donc, Freud immédiatement, et ça, c'est typique chez lui, il généralise à outrance. Donc il écrit à Fliess : « Voilà, c'est ça que j'ai éprouvé, c'est ça qu'on voit dans le mythe », qu'il interprète mal.
Et il dit : « Cela concerne l'humanité entière ». Hein. Et ça, c'est typique de lui. Il fait aussi un rêve, en 1895, le rêve de l'injection à Irma.
Il dit : « Bon, en fait, j'avais vraiment un désir », et c'est symboliquement exprimé dans le rêve. Et il écrit aussi à son ami Fliess : « En fait, tous les rêves sont la réalisation d'un désir ».
Et il va maintenir alors cette généralisation qui est absurde parce qu'enfin, quand on a un cauchemar, ce n'est pas la réalisation d'un désir.
Alors, Freud va interpréter les cauchemars comme étant une, la peur, la peur en quelque sorte du désir qui veut s'exprimer et qui fait qu'on est angoissé, mais que fondamentalement, c'est quand même l'expression d'un désir.
Mais en fait, nous rêvons aussi de nos dégoûts, nous sommes agressifs, etc. etc. Il y a des rêves évidemment qui sont la réalisation d'un désir, mais pas tous. Donc Freud-
Il y a beaucoup de rêves qui sont là pour prévenir un danger. On-
Oui, oui.
rêve d'un-- vous l'expliquez dans le livre, on rêve d'un examen qu'on doit passer, dont on a très peur de-
Oui. Oui.
échouer, voilà, ce genre de choses. J'aimerais revenir sur un exemple que vous aviez cité tout à l'heure. Donc dans le cadre de cette théorie du,
complexe d'Œdipe, la psychanalyse du petit Hans, qui est régulièrement citée comme l'exemple de-
Oui.
de ce que ça donne concrètement, une personne qui serait touchée par le complexe d'Œdipe. Est-ce que vous pouvez nous en parler, de-- qu'est-ce que c'est que cette histoire du petit Hans ?
Oui, alors le petit Hans, qui a cinq ans, qui est élevé selon la doctrine psychanalytique. Freud écrit d'abord un article pour dire à quel point son évolution est bonne.
Et puis justement, il a une phobie, une phobie des chevaux. Il habite en face d'un entrepôt d'où sortent et entrent des chevaux.
Il y a un cheval qui tombe en faisant beaucoup de bruit, hein. Donc c'est ça que va dire le petit Hans, d'ailleurs.
Et donc, Freud et le papa croient immédiatement que c'est à cause du complexe d'Œdipe qu'il a peur des chevaux.
Parce que, raisonne Freud, le cheval est un animal qui a des grandes dents et donc il symbolise ce qui pourrait provoquer la castration, donc couper ce avec quoi on veut évidemment avoir des relations sexuelles avec la mère.
Donc c'est parce que le petit Hans désire sa mère qu'il a peur du cheval. Et donc, le père et Freud vont essayer d'expliquer ça au petit.
Il se fait que, en fait, le petit Hans, il aime beaucoup son papa. Il est très affectueux avec son père. Quand il voit un cheval, il se réfugie tout de suite chez son père.
Et manifestement, il est agressif avec sa maman. Hein, il dit : « Ah ma maman, j'aimerais la battre ». Et donc alors, est-ce que c'est un complexe d'Œdipe ?
« Ma maman, j'aimerais la battre » et il adore son père. Le complexe d'Œdipe, c'est exactement l'inverse. Ce n'est pas un problème pour Freud, hein.
Avec l'inconscient, on explique absolument tout ce qu'on veut. Hein, et la psychanalyse est irréfutable, comme dit Popper.
Et donc Freud dit : « Bah, le, l'agressivité à l'égard de la mère, ce sont des impulsions, euh, incestueuses. Et l'agressivité pour le père, c'est une formation réactionnelle.
Hein, eine Reaktionsbildung. S'il est tellement, euh, gentil avec son père, c'est parce que, en réalité, dans son inconscient, il a envie de le tuer.
Donc peu importe les faits, hein, euh, le psychanalyste a toujours raison. Le psychanalyste, si c'est pile, il a raison, si c'est face, vous avez tort, hein.
Et donc ce qui est assez amusant, c'est que Freud, lorsqu'il explique ce cas, lorsqu'il le publie, il a, il a rajouté, euh,
à peu près vingt ans plus tard, qu'il a revu le petit Hans et que le petit Hans lui dit : « Oui, on m'a raconté cette histoire, je n'en ai pas le moindre souvenir ».
Ce qui montre bien que ce n'était pas tellement traumatisant, hein. Et il faut d'ailleurs dire que les enfants de quatre, cinq ans ont très facilement des phobies de, de grands animaux, hein, des chevaux, des-
Même de petits.
vaches, même petits. Et que la plupart de ces phobies disparaissent tout à fait naturellement. Donc ce n'était pas du tout un exploit thérapeutique.
Alors dans, dans, dans ce dont on vi-on vient de discuter, voilà, il y a beaucoup des, des grands piliers, euh, de la psychanalyse.
Donc pour les citer, hein, euh, l'inconscient, la résistance, le refoulement, le transfert, l'importance de la sexualité et le complexe d'Œdipe. Donc on a évoqué-
Oui.
voilà rapidement le, les notions d'inconscient. On a, on a déblo-- on a parlé du complexe d'Œdipe, de l'importance de la sexualité.
Pour évoquer, voilà, la résistance et le re-le refoulement et peut-être la notion de transfert. De, de quoi s'agit-il ?
Oui, alors tout thérapeute sait que il y a, il y a des résistances à parler de certains sujets, hein, certains thèmes. Donc les, les personnes viennent à une première consultation, ils vous racontent telle et telle chose.
Et puis quand la relation est bonne, ils finissent par vous dire après, il y a aussi telle et telle et telle chose ou telle chose qui leur-- donc il y a des résistances à parler de certaines choses.
Mais Freud, euh, va utiliser ce, ce concept d-d'une façon telle qu'il va avoir toujours raison, euh, dans, dans sa théorie.
Donc il a une théorie. La, la première théorie, c'est celle de la séduction. Donc il pense que toutes les personnes qui, qui souffrent, euh, d'hystérie, de troubles obsessionnels, etc., c'est toujours parce que dans leur enfance,
ils ont été abusés et qu'ils ont refoulé, euh, donc ce, ce souvenir, cet événement.
Et il va donc essayer de faire avouer, euh, cet événement à ses patients, à ses patientes, la plupart étaient des femmes.
Et tant que la personne n'a pas reconnu ce souvenir, elle ne peut pas guérir en quelque sorte. Et alors Freud dit : « Oui, c'est parce qu'elle refoule.
Et c'est parce qu'elle refoule qu'elle résiste ». Hein. La, la résistance, et ce qu'on observe, est la conséquence de ce mécanisme que l'on ne voit pas, mais que l'on doit supposer qui est le refoulement.
Et ça, ça permet à Freud de maintenir absolument toute sa théorie, hein. Il dit toujours que voilà, c'est, c'est une résistance.
Aussi, quand ses disciples sont pas d'accord, quand, quand Adler raconte : « Non, moi, je pense que la sexualité, ce n'est pas toujours l'essentiel, que y a aussi chez les, les, les personnes le désir de se valoriser, de se faire reconnaître, etc.
» Euh, Freud dit : « Bah voilà, il résiste à, à l'importance de la sexualité ». Hein. C'est un problème chez lui, il est névrosé.
Donc c'est, c'est un concept, euh, qui est tout à fait central chez Freud pour maintenir à tout prix sa théorie. Alors, le, le transfert, vous disiez, le transfert est effectivement un concept fondamental chez lui.
Euh, et le-- il raconte qu'un jour, euh, une, une patiente,
euh, lui a sauté au cou et que donc il a expliqué à cette brave dame que en fait, c'était pas lui qui était aimé, mais que à travers lui, euh, elle voulait sauter au cou ou embrasser quelqu'un d'autre.
Ce que la patiente semble avoir accepté comme explication. Donc, il dit : « Le, le transfert, c'est une mésalliance ». C'est le fait, euh, d'attribuer des sentiments à quelqu'un, euh, qui sont en, en réalité dirigés vers quelqu'un d'autre.
Et le, l'exemple par excellence auquel lui, il pense toujours dans, dans, dans ses cures psychanalytiques, c'est que la, la, la personne, en fait, en s'avançant à lui, éprouve des sentiments qu'elle éprouvait à l'égard de ses parents en particulier.
D'où, euh, le fait que la personne s'attache très fort à un analyste, ce que Freud d'ailleurs souligne. Il dit parfois : « La, la, ça confine à la pathologie ».
Les, les gens ne parviennent pas à se détacher, euh, ils ne parlent plus que de l'analyste, ils en sont véritablement amoureux.
Mais, euh, ça explique aussi l'hostilité. Donc quand les gens ne sont pas contents, euh, Freud ne se remet jamais en question.
Il dit : « Voilà, c'est un transfert négatif, un transfert hostile ». Ça permet aussi d'expliquer, euh, à très bon compte, euh, pourquoi des, des gens peuvent être mécontents de leur psychanalyse.
C'est ce qu'il explique dans le cas de Dora, une jeune fille, euh, qui est venue en analyse chez lui et qui, après, euh, quelques semaines, va, va quitter-- Freud d'ailleurs fait des interprétations complètement loufoques.
Et au lieu qu'il se mette en question en disant : « J'ai peut-être dit des bêtises », euh, il va dire : « Voilà, c'est, c'est un transfert négatif.
En réalité, elle veut se venger de quelqu'un d'autre sur moi ».
Oui, oui, oui. Et donc c'est intéressant de, de voir que, euh, Freud développe finalement une série d'outils, de constructions pour toujours retomber sur ses pattes, toujours avoir raison.
Et donc il va, il va tr-trouver un patient qui sera, voilà, type paranoïaque ou, euh, on parlait beaucoup d'hystérie à l'époque.
Oui.
Eh bien, ces mala-, ces, ces véritables pathologies, hein, qui ne sont pas inventées, qui-- les patients, les patients étaient véritablement en situation de souffrance.
Il va toujours trouver une grille de lecture qui passera par le transfert, par la, la, l'obsession sur la sexualité, la, la figure des, des parents et ainsi de suite.
Oui.
Et
c'est, c'est, c'est, euh, des, des outils, voilà, encore une fois, on le rappelle,
qui n'a, qui n'ont pas été trouvés, qui n'ont certainement pas été trouvés de manière scientifique, mais de manière plutôt empirique, 'fin, sur sa propre expérience ou de, un peu
au feeling, voilà, les intuitions comme ça qu'il, qu'il notait au fur et à mesure.
Euh, et il, il, vous expliquez dans le livre qu'il a vraiment voulu, euh, s'approprier et, euh, et expliquer que finalement, la psychanalyse, c'est lui et ça n'est personne d'autre.
Et il incarne la psychanalyse. Et on, on ne peut pas penser le, le contraire de, de ce qu'il explique. Et, euh, pour, pour finalement garder une forme de contrôle, euh, sur sa discipline qu'il avait mise en place.
Euh, mais ça n'a pas vraiment marché puisqu'il y a eu beaucoup de divisions, beaucoup de séparations. De nombreux de, de ses élèves ont quitté l'école.
On pense par exemple à, à Carl Jung. Euh, et c'est d'ailleurs amusant que Carl Jung quitte so-son école et va inventer non pas la psychanalyse, mais, euh, la psychologie analytique.
Et donc, euh, c'est, c'est-- un point que je voulais aborder avec vous, c'est que finalement, au début, c'était peut-être très concentré, un, un bloc très, euh, voilà, Freud gardait la main sur la psy-la psychanalyse.
Et puis petit à petit, ça s'est de plus en plus, de plus en plus divisé, différentes écoles, différents pays. Et aujourd'hui, si je prends
500 psychanalystes en Europe ou même, disons, même, disons 500 psychanalystes à Paris, que je les confronte à un patient, à un, un problème à, à élucider, euh, tout à fait possible, d'après ce que vous expliquez dans le livre hein, que
j'obtienne 500 réponses différentes au problème.
Euh, c'est, c'est, bon, c'est, c'est déjà intéressant en soi, mais la question à laquelle j'ai, j'ai envie d'approcher, c'est que
tous les reproches que nous avons, voilà, que, que vous avez pu développer aujourd'hui, euh, au sujet d-de la psychanalyse, de, de ce qui ne va pas, de voilà, et qu'on va pouvoir continuer à explorer ensemble, euh-
Une défense que j'entends régulièrement au sujet de la psychanalyse, c'est : Ah non, mais tu ne peux pas prendre cet exemple-là.
Ce n'est pas représentatif, c'est anecdotique. D'accord, ces psychanalystes ont dit ça, mais ça ne met pas en, en défaut l'entièreté de la discipline
puisque, voilà, je le disais, on va trouver de nombreuses contradictions, de nombreuses personnes qui
pratiquent la psychanalyse de manière très différente.
Et donc finalement, j'ai l'impression que de nombreux défenseurs de la psychanalyse vont lire votre livre et dire : Oui, mais Freud, c'est vieux.
Oui, mais d'accord, il y en a encore qui écoutent Freud aujourd'hui, mais ceux-là, il ne faut pas les écouter. Il y a beaucoup de choses à sauver dans la psychanalyse parce que justement, c'est très fragmenté, parce que c'est très divisé.
Qu'est-ce que vous leur répondez ?
Oui, mais en fait, Freud lui-même dit très clairement que, euh, il, il faut pas rejeter des parties de, de la psychanalyse.
Il n'a, il n'a lui-même remis en question que le, que la théorie de, de la séduction, là où il croyait que les troubles provenaient de, de véritables séductions.
Alors après, il a dit : Non, c'est plutôt des fantasmes. Mais en dehors de ça, Freud n'a, n'a quasi jamais, euh, écrit qu'il s'était trompé sur tel ou tel sujet, hein. Donc,
euh, les psychanalystes n'utilisent pas de poubelles. C'est ce qui les distingue des scientifiques. Les scientifiques,
euh, bon, ils ont des, des hypothèses, des théories, ils observent méthodiquement et puis ils mettent à la poubelle une série de choses qui ne tiennent pas la route et ils conservent heureusement d'autres choses, sinon la science n'évoluerait pas.
Euh, tandis que les psychanalystes rajoutent. Alors, il y a effectivement, depuis, depuis Freud, il y a, il y a trente-six psychanalystes, euh, trente-six écoles de psychanalyse.
Il y a l'école kleinianienne, il y a l'école de Ferenczi, de Rank, de Reich, de Jung, d'Adler. Et il y a, il y a toutes les écoles lacaniennes.
En France, il y a plus de trente écoles lacaniennes différentes qui, qui ont aussi des, des règles d'admission différentes, mais aussi d'interprétation, etc.
Et donc, euh, il est évident que la psychologie ne peut pas fonctionner de manière rigoureusement scientifique dans, dans, dans, dans tout ce qu'elle fait.
Donc, il y a des moments, quand on veut comprendre l'histoire d'un individu, euh, bon, on ne fait pas de la psychologie expérimentale.
Donc il faut là pouvoir mettre ensemble des éléments, etc. Seulement, ce qui caractérise les personnes qui alors font ce qu'on peut appeler la psychologie compréhensive ou herméneutique,
c'est qu'ils savent que leur façon de voir est, est, est un modèle qui permet de, d'articuler une série de faits, mais que c'est un modèle qui doit être confronté à d'autres façons d'interpréter.
Et donc la, la communauté, si vous voulez, de, des chercheurs, que ce soit donc en histoire, en psychanalyse, etc, devrait pouvoir, euh, s'autoréguler.
Or, ce n'est pas ce qui s'est du tout passé chez Freud. Euh,
dans l'histoire de la psychanalyse, quand, quand des disciples n'étaient pas d'accord avec lui, il n'a pas dit : Bon, OK, c'est un aspect dont nous devons tenir compte, mais il a dit : Voilà, vous résistez, vous refoulez, vous êtes malade mental.
Hein, il traite son disciple Adler de paranoïaque, ce qui est complètement ridicule, hein, quand on voit la biographie d'Adler.
Il traite Jung de malade mental, de dément, ce qui est tout aussi grotesque, etc. Donc euh, alors, ses, ses disciples ont d'autres façons, si vous voulez, d'interpréter les difficultés des gens.
Ils vont, ils vont insister. Par exemple, Adler insiste beaucoup sur, euh, l'importance de se faire reconnaître, de la valorisation de soi.
Je pense que c'est effectivement une des dimensions fondamentales de l'existence de chacun. Hein, personnellement, je pense avoir, euh, passé plus de temps à essayer d'avoir un statut, de, de, d'être reconnu, d'être estimé que, que d'avoir du plaisir sexuel.
Enfin, ça aussi, ça m'a intéressé, mais euh, donc-- alors que pour Freud, à l'époque, voilà, la sexualité explique tout.
Et quand Adler vient avec des concepts qu'il a pêchés chez Nietzsche, hein, dont il était un lecteur assidu, Freud va le remballer.
Donc voilà, ce qui caractérise la psychanalyse, c'est, en tout cas freudienne, c'est qu'elle est dogmatique. Elle rajoute évidemment des choses, éventuellement.
Hein, euh, Freud lui-même a rajouté certains concepts. Par exemple, le concept de pulsion de mort, c'est pas lui qui l'a inventé.
Elle vient, il vient de, de Sabina Spielrein. Enfin, peu importe. Donc, il a, il a rajouté des choses, mais il n'a jamais enlevé.
Et donc, dans mon livre, je parle surtout des piliers de la psychanalyse en disant : Alors, bien sûr, vous pouvez maintenant dire Melanie Klein a raconté ceci, Ferenczi a raconté ça, et tel psychanalyste américain raconte encore autre chose.
Mais euh, il y a, il y a ces piliers qui demeurent toujours. L'inconscient tel que Freud l'envisageait, euh, la notion de transfert, la notion de complexe de castration, etc.
C'est toujours les, les mêmes bases, exactement comme euh, il y a, il y a diverses églises chrétiennes, hein, à commencer par l'Église catholique.
Et même là, il y a déjà un peu de, de diversité. Mais alors, quand on entre dans, dans l'univers des églises protestantes, vous avez une infinité de, enfin, en tout cas beaucoup de chapelles différentes.
Euh, mais il y a des bases, bien sûr. Hein, il y a, on, voilà, on croit d'un tel et tel, euh, on croit bien que, que le Christ est, est le Fils de Dieu, que il est mort sous la croix, qu'il est, mais qu'il est ressuscité.
La même chose en psychanalyse. Il y a aussi là des, des données fondamentales.
De nombreuses écoles différentes, mais des fondamen-, des fondamentaux, des piliers-
Oui.
...sur lesquels tout repose. Et donc, vous dites : Puisque ces piliers sont Fragiles, n'ont pas, n'ont pas de valeur scientifique, sont, sont trompeurs, ne valent finalement rien.
Tout s'écroule et il ne reste plus rien d'intéressant. Est-ce que c'est ça que vous dites ? Est-ce que, est-ce que vous ne pourriez--
Par exemple, si, si on va chercher du côté de Carl Jung, qui est quand même
parfois cité comme ayant trouvé des idées intéressantes, euh, est-ce que, est-ce qu'il n'y a plus rien à sauver ou bien est-ce que vous gardez quand même quelques, quelques trouvailles qui ont été faites au cours du vingtième siècle ?
Si on prend l'ensemble de la littérature psychanalytique, il y a évidemment des observations intéressantes hein, euh. Il y a des gens intelligents qui ont aussi fait des observations.
Donc tout, tout n'est pas à rejeter, euh, bien sûr. Et même chez Freud. Mais chez Freud, en fait, ce que l'on peut trouver intéressant, c'est des choses qui ont été dites avant lui, hein.
Donc, par exemple, l'importance de l'enfance. Montaigne en parlait déjà hein. Donc euh, dit : « Voilà, nos, nos coutumes se développent avec le lait de, de nos nourrices ».
Donc euh. Et donc lorsqu'on essaye de voir ce qui est vraiment spécifiquement freudien, euh, ben, il n'y a pas, il y a pas beaucoup qui qui demeure hein.
C'est, c'est, c'est étonnant. Moi, la première fois que, que j'ai lu cette phrase, euh, d'un, d'un, d'un psychiatre de l'époque de Freud qui dit : « Voilà, il y a chez Freud du bon et, euh, du mauvais,
mais le bon n'est pas de lui et ce qui est de lui n'est pas bon ».
Euh, donc ce qu'il y a de, de spécifique chez Freud, c'est des généralisations. Bon, par exemple, le psychiatre Grissinger, déjà dans les années 1850, écrit que dans, dans les rêves, il y a souvent l'expression de désir.
Euh, mais ce que fait Freud, c'est dire : tout rêve est toujours la réalisation hallucinatoire d'un désir. Donc, il y a chez lui la constitution d'une essence, une généralisation, euh, qui, qui alors
fait de, de ces idées qui étaient déjà dans l'air avant lui, qui fait chez Freud des thèses qui sont tout à fait discutables ou que, que l'on peut considérer comme loufoques.
Euh, j'aimerais revenir sur un point que, que vous avez abordé au tout début de notre entretien, quand vous parliez de votre aventure, donc à Nimègue, là où vous avez pris conscience des, des, des problématiques euh, euh, liées à la psychanalyse.
Euh, vous expliquez que les psychologues, là-bas, voyaient la psychanalyse comme une idéologie bourgeoise qui faisait le jeu des autorités en donnant invariablement des explications intrapersonnelles, donc des, voilà, vous le disiez hein,
des pulsions, fixations anales, complexes d'Œdipe, la castration et ainsi de suite,
euh, et en négligeant les facteurs socioéconomiques des troubles mentaux.
Oui.
Euh, quand, quand je lis ça,
je, je, j'ai l'impression d'entendre, euh, une logique de, de grands jeux systémiques qui sont en place et la psychanalyse qui serait alors là pour finalement dire : Non, non, non, rien de systémique, rien de global, rien, aucun ordre de pouvoir.
Tout ça, c'est juste une maladie vraiment personnelle, un, un, un vice qui est en vous et qui ne vient que de vous.
Oui, oui. Oui, alors, les psychanalystes reconnaissent bien encore l'importance, euh, surtout de, de la petite enfance hein, de, de traumatismes subis, euh, dans la petite enfance.
Mais, mais globalement, euh, ils attachent très peu, euh, d'intérêt, euh, à, à des conditionnements externes. Donc euh, on peut toujours expliquer des, des, des phénomènes en faisant des attributions internes ou externes hein.
Et bon, c'est vrai dans, dans, dans nos relations tout le temps hein. Si, si quelqu'un arrive en retard, nous pouvons tout de suite penser que c'est parce qu'il nous
n'attache pas assez d'importance, que si, si nous étions importants, il serait parti bien à l'heure.
Mais on peut aussi dire : Voilà, il n'a pas eu de chance, euh, il a raté le métro. Voilà, il y a des circonstances atténuantes.
Et donc ça, c'est vrai pour, pour tous nos comportements, y compris pour ce que nous faisons nous-mêmes hein. On peut aussi attribuer ses mérites, euh, à soi-même ou à l'extérieur, à des facteurs externes.
Alors moi, moi qui suis devenu un psychologue d'orientation comportementale, euh, j'ai tendance à prendre fortement en compte les facteurs externes.
L'épithète, l'adjectif qui m'avait frappé dans l'explication de, de ce psychologue aux Pays-Bas, c'était : c'est une idéologie bourgeoise.
Donc qui, qui tend non pas à favoriser, comme, comme ce que vous expliquez, voilà, non pas à accepter les facteurs externes à l'expliquer, mais à les rejeter.
Et donc ce mot bourgeois, ça, voilà, ça sous-entend que c'est finalement, c'est pensé comme tel, c'est imaginé comme tel, c'est un outil de la bourgeoisie pour empêcher surtout qu'on s'attarde à des, sur des explications systémiques.
Quand on voit la biographie de Freud, on voit qu'étant jeune, il avait, il avait envie d'être un peu le, le révolutionnaire hein.
Donc euh, il voulait penser à l'encontre euh-
De la bourgeoisie.
De la bourgeoisie, etc. Euh, mais progressivement, il est devenu quand même quelqu'un de l'establishment hein. Il y a des révolutions qui se font à Vienne, il y a des ouvriers qui se font tuer.
On en voit nulle trace dans ses lettres, ça ne, ça ne l'intéresse pas. Il est devenu vraiment un homme, un homme de droite.
Et c'est la même chose pour Lacan hein. Lacan qui paraît quelqu'un de subversif, euh, qui se permettait aussi n'importe quoi hein.
Et dans le fond, euh, quelqu'un aussi de droite. D'ailleurs, il y a plusieurs de ses analysants qui ont, qui ont écrit leur psychanalyse chez Lacan.
Certain Godin, par exemple, ou bien aussi Gérard Radatte. Tous les deux disent : Ce qui, ce qui m'énervait chez Lacan, c'était que le, le, le seul journal qu'il lisait, c'était Le Figaro.
Et alors ça m'énervait, dit Godin, parce qu'il lisait pendant, pendant mon analyse et j'entendais qu'il, qu'il manipulait le journal.
J'entendais les pages qui étaient froissées de ce journal, cet horrible journal de droite Donc Lacan aussi euh n'était pas en réalité pas non plus vraiment un, un, un progressiste.
Donc vous dites ce n'est pas une coïncidence.
C'est peut-être pas une coïncidence, mais évidemment quand on explique toujours les choses par l'intérieur, euh on, on, on, on a tendance à, à ne pas être compatissant pour les gens qui n'ont pas eu de chance hein.
Mh.
Surtout quand on a eu soi-même hein. Donc les nantis, les gens qui vont bien, bah ils n'imaginent pas que, que les autres, qu'eux ils ont eu tout simplement beaucoup de chance et que les autres n'ont pas eu de chance.
Ce serait alors une partie de l'explication.
Oui oui oui oui. Les-- vous savez les, les, les psychanalystes qui sont de gauche, c'est souvent de, de la gauche caviar hein.
Bah Gérard Miller, c'est, c'est justement-
Ouais
...maoïste plutôt extrême gauche.
Oui surtout autrefois et aussi son frère euh, ce sont des gens de gauche, mais vous savez, ils habitent dans le seizième, des grands appartements.
Oui.
Ils sont très riches.
Extrême gauche caviar.
Oui tout à fait. Donc madame Zulinesco aussi qui se dit de gauche hein, et que tous, tous ces gens sont, sont très riches-
Ouais, ouais
...et se fréquentent entre eux et n'ont pas la moindre attention, la moindre compassion pour les gens qui, qui sont dans la misère.
D'accord, d'accord. Euh un autre point qui, qui parmi tous ceux que nous allons aborder aujourd'hui euh, est sans doute celui qui, qui m'a le plus frappé en préparant cette émission, c'est
le, le fa- la fameuse situation lors du, des grands débats qui ont eu lieu en France il y a une dizaine d'années à l'Assemblée nationale dans le cadre de, du projet de loi pour euh le mariage homosexuel, le, le mariage pour tous,
où en France parce que c'est la France, on reçoit dans le cadre de, de cette législation euh
à l'Assemblée nationale, on reçoit euh des psychanalystes pour leur demander-
Oui, Witter par exemple, oui.
Voilà, on, on, on les reçoit pour leur demander leur avis sur la situation. Est-ce que ce serait une bonne idée de l'autoriser, etc.
Et tous euh les psychanalystes euh hommes et femmes qui sont reçus à l'Assemblée nationale prennent position pour dire que non, ce serait une très mauvaise idée d'autoriser ce nouveau mode de fonctionnement euh de, de, de, de l'unité familiale.
Oui.
Euh en disant : mais regardez, la première chose que un enfant, un nourrisson doit apprendre à faire, c'est euh faire la différence entre son père et sa mère.
Et donc c'est comme ça qu'il apprend la notion de différence et c'est comme ça que petit à petit, il apprend à réfléchir.
Et donc si demain euh des enfants sont élevés par deux parents de même sexe, eh bien, ils ne pourront plus penser, ils ne pourront plus réfléchir, ils ne pourront plus parler.
Euh et donc c'est, c'est absolument, absolument ridicule et affreusement conservateur. Quelle analyse est-ce que vous faites de ce positionnement euh conservateur et voilà en défense d'un certain statu quo ?
Alors, Jung raconte, il a plusieurs fois raconté que quand il était en discussion avec Freud euh et qu'ils n'étaient pas d'accord, Freud disait : écoutez, je l'ai pensé et ça doit donc être comme cela.
Hein, ce qui est vraiment la formule par excellence du rationaliste au mauvais sens du terme. Donc Freud pense quelque chose et il croit que c'est ça la, la réalité.
Donc les, les psychanalystes euh sont très souvent des rationalistes au mauvais sens du terme, c'est-à-dire des rationalistes qui ne, qui ne vont pas voir très concrètement comment ça se passe dans la réalité.
Parce qu'ils ont le droit évidemment de faire des hypothèses en disant voilà en fonction de ma théorie, je pense que euh si euh voilà des--
si un enfant est élevé par, par, par deux femmes, euh à la troisième génération, il va devenir schizophrène hein.
C'est le genre de choses qu'on a entendues euh dans ces circonstances, qu'on entend encore. Ben il faut, il, il faut aller voir.
Il faut peut-être aussi sortir des frontières, aller voir dans d'autres pays comment ça se passe hein, en Hollande, aux États-Unis.
Alors est-ce qu'il y a des cas, faire des statistiques, observer,
donc être empirique et, et en tirer des conclusions. Alors peut-être que, que ce n'est pas une bonne chose statistiquement hein, mais euh décréter comme ça parce que je l'ai pensé, c'est ça la réalité,
euh c'est, c'est, c'est tout, c'est tout le malheur de la psychanalyse.
Les psychanalystes pensent quelque chose et ils croient que c'est vrai. Ils font une interprétation. Freud dit voilà, si vous avez peur des serpents, c'est parce qu'en fait, vous avez peur des pénis.
Euh voilà. Ce qui manque à la psychanalyse, fondamentalement, c'est le souci d'une vérification de leurs hypothèses. Ils peuvent faire des hypothèses même farfelues hein.
Il y a des choses qui, qui ont paru farfelues dans l'histoire des sciences.
Mais donc là, finalement, vous vous attaquez à leur manque de démarche scientifique et au fait que-
Absolument
...ils pensent quelque chose et ils présument que c'est vrai immédiatement.
Là, là, là où je voulais euh diriger notre, notre discussion, c'est le fait que ces, ces positions fermes de non, je-- c'est comme ça que ça marche, j'en suis certain, il n'y a, il n'y a aucun doute, sont,
j'ai l'impression, systématiquement au service d'une forme de conservatisme et de maintien du statu quo, par exemple, le maintien d'une structure familiale classique hétérosexuelle de non, ça a toujours été comme ça, ça doit rester comme ça.
Autre exemple, le, le, la situ-, le cas de la filiation. Quel sera le nom de famille du nouveau-né ? Ça a toujours été le nom du père.
Euh et si on autorisait la transmission du nom de famille de la mère, les psychanalystes se sont levés à ce moment-là pour dire non, non, non, surtout pas.
Le-- ça doit rester comme ça a toujours été pour euh voilà des raisons qui étaient les leurs hein. Euh est-ce que la psychanalyse, dans son ensemble, est un outil, de manière générale, de, de, du maintien de l'ordre établi tel qu'il a toujours été ?
Oui, d'une certaine façon. Euh d'ailleurs, c'est typique
en France quand même, quand on voit euh même en Belgique euh, bon la plupart des psychanalystes qui réussissent sont quand même des gens qui euh ont un certain standing et Qui ne fréquentent pas
les malheureux qui dorment dehors et, et qui vont très mal.
Ah, il y en a qui travaillent bien sûr dans des, dans des institutions, mais...
Oui. Do-do-donc j'ai l'impression que ce que vous dites, c'est, euh, indirectement parce que les psychanalystes sont de manière générale plutôt-
Oui
...des personnes aisées, plutôt des personnes, voilà, qui, qui sont, euh, à droite du spectre politique. Pour ces raisons, ils vont avoir tendance à être plutôt, euh, conservateurs, conservatrices dans leur approche.
Oui, et alors évidemment, comme, comme ils font
des attributions internes, pour reprendre le, ce, un concept majeur de la psychanalyse,
comme ils expliquent que les choses vont mal par des facteurs internes à la personne, ils ne remettent pas tellement en question la société ni, ni ce qui se passe dans, dans, dans le contexte.
La con-, le, l'impression que moi, j'avais eue en, en, en vous lisant, c'était que, voilà, hi-historiquement,
sur les deux mille, trois, trois mille, cinq mille ans qui, qui nous précèdent,
on a, on a eu régulièrement des institutions telles que la science, la médecine, qui nous expliquaient très sérieusement, par exemple, que il est évident que les femmes ont un cerveau plus petit que ceux des hommes.
Il est évident que, euh, les, les femmes sont hystériques. Il est évident que le rôle de la femme est de rester à la maison pour des raisons, voilà, euh, que ce soit médicales-
Oui, oui
...euh, les raisons établies par la science, des raisons politiques, voilà, très claires, inquestionnables. C'est gravé dans le marbre, c'est comme ça.
Et, et j'ai, j'ai, j'ai eu souvent l'impression, en vous lisant, que la psychanalyse était un de ces outils, une de ces institutions qui étaient là pour graver dans le marbre,
euh, voilà, des, des, des choses liées, par exemple, à l'homosexualité, par exemple à la place de la femme, pour vraiment, euh,
maintenir au rang d'opprimées ces populations qui devaient surtout rester minorisées-
Oui
...dans la société.
Je ne crois pas que ce soit délibéré, que-- je ne crois pas beaucoup qu'il y ait là une organisation, un complot, mais, mais la, la, la théorie aboutit à ces résultats.
Oui.
Fatalement, hein, euh. Et, ben Freud est vraiment victime aussi de, de ses préjugés, hein. Il parle de l'infé-, de l'infériorité naturelle de la femme.
Il ajoute même, je crois, dans, dans la, dans la phrase qui, qui est une, qui est une donnée incontestable. Mais fondamentalement,
notamment dans, dans un livre qui semble mettre en question la civilisation, hein, le livre de, de 1930, La, Le malaise dans la civilisation.
Finalement, il dit : « Si, si nous sommes mal à l'aise, c'est parce qu'en, en réalité, nous, nous, nous avons tué le père primitif, nos ancêtres, et que nous sommes toujours victimes de, euh, ce meurtre primordial, originaire.
Nous, nous, nous ne le savons pas, c'est dans notre inconscient, mais c'est ça, fondamentalement, qui nous met mal à l'aise ».
C'est une idée complètement idiote, hein, c'est . D'ailleurs, quand, quand Jones, son biographe, euh, qui à l'époque était son ami, a lu ça, il a supplié Freud de, de ne pas écrire ça.
Enfin, du point de vue de la théorie biologique, euh, cette théorie la-lamarckienne à laquelle Freud adhérait, euh, c'est, c'est tout à fait fou de penser que, que donc c'est parce que les, les, les premiers hommes tuaient,
ont tué le père primitif que, que nous éprouvons de la culpabilité.
Oui.
C'est, c'est assez dingue. Il faut-- quand on lit Malaise dans la civilisation, il faut, il faut le lire de près.
Parce que ce, ce qui est typique d'ailleurs, quand moi, j'ai lu Dolto quand j'étais jeune, j'avais trouvé qu'il y avait pas mal de choses intéressantes, mais c'est parce que nous avons tendance à, à, à zapper, à laisser de côté ce qui est absurde.
Mh, mh.
Mais si on prend la peine de relire tout ça en ayant un œil critique, on se dit : « Mais c'est dingue, cette histoire ».
C'est la même chose pour Freud. C'est, c'est la même chose aussi probablement pour des religions. Là aussi, on, on s'arrange, on dit : « Ben il faut, il faut interpréter.
Enfin, vous savez, l'histoire Adam et Ève, c'est pas du tout-- c'est, ils n'ont pas existé. C'est, c'est des métaphores, c'est, c'est un peu de la mythologie, c'est des mythes pour faire comprendre que...
» Oui, mais bon, alors, donc ça, on, on, on laisse tomber. Et qu'est-ce qu'on laisse tomber d'autre, finalement ?
C'est ça. C'est ça, c'est ça.
Si, si on commence à avoir l'esprit très critique, comme moi, comme moi, j'ai développé le mien,
euh, par suite d'une série de circonstances, pas parce que je suis plus malin, mais parce que j'ai eu la chance de rencontrer, euh, des personnes et que j'ai fait telle et telle et telle lecture.
Bon ben là, on se rend compte que, euh, en lisant de près, euh, on découvre qu'il y a des choses qui sont folles, euh, et que il y a aussi des choses qui paraissent raisonnables, bien sûr, qu'on peut essayer de sauver.
Mais enfin, dans le cas de la psychanalyse, je crois qu'il y a plus de choses folles que de choses à conserver.
Magnifique conclusion. Nous arrivons en effet au, au terme de notre entretien. Est-ce qu'il y a d'autres, d'autres sujets, d'autres thèmes que nous avons oublié d'aborder, que, que vous voudriez explorer avant, avant que nous nous quittions ?
Oui, la seule chose que je voudrais dire, c'est que les, les, les personnes qui, qui me critiquent, qui ne m'aiment pas, disent que j'ai passé ma vie à critiquer Freud.
C'est faux. Euh, j'ai fait beaucoup d'autres choses. Euh, j'ai fait des thérapies comportementales, j'ai enseigné, etc. Et je-- dans mes cours, je parlais bien sûr de la psychanalyse, mais pas que.
Et puis j'ai aussi écrit d'autres choses. Par exemple, le livre, euh, qui est mon préféré, d'une certaine manière, c'est La gestion de soi, euh, où il est très peu question de, de Freud.
Euh, j'ai aussi écrit avec une spécialiste, euh, de la, de l'enfance, un livre qui s'appelle L'accompagnement psychologique des enfants malades.
J'ai écrit des livres sur, sur, sur la colère, sur l'angoisse, sur les phobies. Donc, euh, je collabore, euh, très régulièrement à la revue Science, pseudo-science, qui est en ligne.
On peut voir là mes articles et on verra que il y a toute une série d'articles, euh, où il n'est pas question de psychanalyse.
Donc, je ne suis pas un obsédé de, de-- je ne suis pas, euh, euh Vraiment pris par la haine de Freud, comme disent certains.
Certains disent : « Oui, vous critiquez Freud, c'est parce que vous le détestez. » Non, je critique Freud parce qu'il y a matière à critique.
Je suis loin d'être le premier à le faire. Euh, Karl Popper, Piaget, Wittgenstein, Bouvreuse,
etc. etc. Donc, il y a plein de, de, de gens très raisonnables, euh, de, de psychanalystes eux-mêmes qui ont abandonné la psychanalyse, comme Albert Ellis, comme Beck, etc.
Et, et donc moi, je voudrais quand même dire que je n'ai pas fait que ça dans ma vie.
Voilà, vous n'avez pas fait que ça. Simplement, nous en parlons aujourd'hui parce que-
Oui, oui
...vous sortez un livre ce mois-ci, euh, Les désillusions de la psychanalyse, euh-
Auquel j'ai beaucoup travaillé. Bien que c'était la reprise d'un ancien livre, euh, j'y ai intégré beaucoup de nouvelles choses.
Voilà. Et comme je le disais, donc, sorti ce mois-ci, disponible aux éditions Mardaga. Et je mettrai le lien pour se le procurer dans la description de ce podcast.
Je vous remercie pour ces plus de septante minutes passées avec moi, Jacques Van Rillaer.
Oui, oui. Merci beaucoup aussi, euh, de me donner l'occasion ainsi de, de diffuser un peu, euh, mes convictions en espérant être utile à d'autres personnes.
C'est quand même ça l'important.
Mais ce sera certainement le cas. Je vous remercie, Jacques Van Rillaer, et, euh, je vous dis à dans deux semaines pour un prochain épisode. Au revoir.
Au revoir.
Voilà, je vous remercie d'avoir écouté jusqu'au bout et n'hésitez pas à me faire des retours sur cette interview. Je serais ravi de savoir si,
euh, ça vous a plu, si ça vous a intéressé, si, euh, si ça a changé votre vie d'entendre ce, ce genre de discours sur la psychanalyse, si au contraire, vous n'avez pas du tout adhéré.
Je, voilà, je serais très intéressé de, d'entendre tout ça.
Je me permets de vous rappeler que en avril prochain, je donne une formation en journalisme, euh, ouverte non seulement aux personnes qui voudraient se lancer dans l'exercice de, des interviews format podcast,
mais aussi, euh, toutes celles et ceux qui, qui aiment ce podcast et qui voudraient en savoir plus sur
ma façon de travailler et, voilà, et la, les, les coulisses de ce projet.
Dans quelques semaines, j'aurai le plaisir de recevoir Myriam Leroy pour la deuxième fois. C'est la, c'est la seule, la seule personne qui a le droit de revenir dans le podcast une deuxième fois.
Et, et elle reviendra même, en fait, une troisième fois, mais on en parlera plus tard.
Euh, n'hésitez pas à m'envoyer, euh, des questions pour elle, puisque on parlera exclusivement de, euh, son procès et de son long combat judiciaire contre son harceleur présumé.
Et on reviendra donc sur tout ça fin de ce mois-ci dans Septante Minutes Avec. Je vous dis à très bientôt. Bisous bisous.